we explore pre touch sensing for mobile
interaction this emerging modality uses
a self
of touchscreen to sense multi-touch
above the screen
as well as grip around the outer edges
of the device
anticipatory techniques proactively
adapt the interface to the current grip
and the approach of the fingers
for example our prototype video player
has an ad-lib interface that
spontaneously presents interactive
elements just in the nick of time
initially there is no interface the
video is the focus of attention but when
the hand approaches this indicates a
change in context and so the controls
fade in yet the interface recedes into
the background when the user moves out
of proximity however if the user holds
the device one-handed only a subset of
the controls come forward and in a
manner particularly suited to the thumb
instead of sliders the user dials to
scrub through the timeline or adjust the
volume while holding the device in the
other hand brings the controls to that
side instead
with the second thumb a richer set of
options becomes available
and is distinct from a pinch-to-zoom
which again fades out single finger
controls
we also explore pre touch as a way to
provide a calm web browsing experience
free of clutter
only when the user approaches do the
hyperlinks reveal themselves and they do
so in a rich way that feathers off with
the contours of the finger and when the
user comes in with multiple fingers the
interface again recognizes this as a
distinct state
this affords self-revelation of
multi-touch gestures such as providing
hints for a two finger swipe to switch
tabs
with a simple mode switch the pre touch
channel can also be used to refer to and
highlight content during collaboration
pree touch can also act as a
back-channel that augments touch events
hence a rapid tap that just happens to
land on a small target can be discounted
or fine adjustments that end up on a
large target can be mapped to a nearby
small control instead
as another example a touch preceded by
rapid lateral motion can immediately be
interpreted as a flick whereas a touch
preceded by precise motion instead
triggers text selection
finally pre touch lends itself to hybrid
touch plus hover gestures which combine
on-screen touch with sensing fingers
directly above the screen
for example we can enhance selection by
pressing on an object while bringing
another finger into range to call up
options this allows efficient commands
at a comfortable and convenient location
however since we can also sense grip
when using just the thumb the technique
gracefully degrades to one-handed use
hybrid touch also has potential for
games such as a soccer game
we have demonstrated how pre touch
affords interfaces that are more
responsive to the fine-grained context
of use that are easier to reach and more
comfortable to use and that engender
more communicative more expressive and
more entertaining ways of interacting
through touch
taken as a whole our exploration of pre
touch hints that the evolution of mobile
touch may still be in its infancy with
many possibilities unbounded by the
flatland of the touchscreen yet to
explore
you